hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
over the next half an hour we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
daily mirror economist susie boniface
and the conservative commentator tim
montgomery so a very good friday evening
to both of you
so let's take a look at the front pages
first of all shall we and the daily
telegraph says downing street is being
urged to
intervene in the escalating feud between
the former
first minister of scotland alex salmond
and his successor nicholas sturgeon whom
he's accused of leadership
failure the president journal carries
the same
story saying alex simon has demanded the
resignations
of a series of top scottish government
and snp officials
the eye says police and teaching unions
have criticized the decision to continue
with the vaccine rollout on the basis of
age rather than prioritizing frontline
workers
don't wreck it now as the express
headline with england's deputy chief
medical officer jonathan van tan warning
the battle against
kovid is not yet won and it's too early
to
relax the guardian leads with a
declassified report by u.s
intelligence services which says the
saudi crown prince mohammed bin salman
approved the murder of the washington
post journalist jamal khashoggi
in 2018. the time says tens of thousands
of young people will get their first
step onto
the housing ladder thanks to a new
mortgage guarantee scheme
that's due to be announced in the budget
next week
queens as happy as harry is the mirror's
headline after prince harry's interview
on u.s television and the daily star has
its own unique take on the duke of
sussex
bus tour of los angeles with james
corden
and the sun leads with its own exclusive
interview with a former contestant from
the reality television show the
apprentice
so susie boniface and tim montgomery are
here with me tonight and lots of
different headlines around actually
different
papers covering different stories but
you've picked two that do
go with the same thing and that was the
evidence being given today
in scotland by alex salmond the daily
telegraph is the first paper you've
picked out
salmon denounces sturgeon scotland's
leadership has
failed susie yeah there's an awful lot
of
you know westminster bubble type gossip
uh and coverage of this in the papers
about how what this means for the union
and what it means for the conservatives
or the labor party and things like that
but at the root of all this there are 10
women who made allegations about alex
salmond
who uh we know were badly let down
by the investigation that was held
initially by the
scottish authorities and who when it
went to court
um there were 13 charges 12 of them he
was acquitted and one of them was found
to be not proven
and they have said while watching all
this now unfold as he is
trying to um you know point the finger
of blame at someone for what's happened
that watching all this is more traumatic
for them than the actual initial court
case was
and mr samuel is not guilty of any
crimes has admitted behaving
inappropriately with these women
and he's now trying to rehabilitate
his reputation after these uh court
troubles he's had
you know by basically by attacking a
woman albeit politically
it's uh it's not very pleasant to watch
well yes i mean he was cleared of 13
charges of sexual assault um
the government there has admitted it
acted unlawfully during its
investigation uh into the initial
complaints um what's your reaction
to all of this tim and i mean there were
six hours of testimony today weren't
there this is the scottish parliamentary
inquiry examining
uh the scottish government's botched
handling of the harassment allegations
what do you make of it
well i have a lot of sympathy what with
what susie has just said that you know
there's obviously
um misconduct from alex salmond
uh in how he treated uh women and we
should not forget that
but as you say um anna um the scottish
government has admitted it
acted unlawfully it had to pay a huge
amount of
costs to alex salmon scottish taxpayers
had to pay those costs because of the
mishandling
of this whole affair by the scottish
government so it's quite
right that this is investigated and
what we have seen throughout this saga
is an unwillingness a lack of
cooperation
from nicola sturgeon and the the
scottish government
and civil servants acting on their
behalf
to the parliamentary inquiry to
newspapers the spectator had to go to
the high court
this last week in order to get important
documents
given to you know into the public domain
and
there seems to be a stench of cover-up
in how nicola sturgeon has been handling
this
and it just seems to be such a contrast
with how she wants to present herself
to the electorate on covert where she's
been doing her daily press conferences
on this whole affair and she does seem
to be vulnerable to the charge that alex
salmond
is making that she did seem and
more than uh more than
interested in that he was prosecuted for
this and perhaps
got rid of a rival forever and um it's
ugly
and but the com the complicity of the
scottish civil servants in this
the idea that they've grown too close to
the snp
you know that that matters because we
need an independent civil service
to stop politicians running a mark this
story
also makes the front of the p j as you
might imagine
on the subject of nicolas sturgeon she
of course will be answering questions um
and she does say she denies breaking the
ministerial code
um she's talked about alex almond
creating wild conspiracy theories that
are untrue and says there's not a shred
of evidence that there's any conspiracy
the question as well i guess susie is to
what extent this could
uh filter through their hollywood
elections coming up in may
what do you think voters will make of
this will they see
a division as being a problem or do you
think it will make no difference to how
they view
the party i think people
that have been talking about that today
are more westminster bubble stuff really
because your average voter
assumes that politicians scheme against
each other
all the time and if nicola sturgeon is
found to have done that
and if she doesn't have to lose her job
over it over misleading parliament or
something
i can't see that voters are going to be
sufficiently bothered in sufficient
numbers
to learn that she decided to knife if
she did decide to knife
um her predecessor in that way and she's
a very clever woman i very much doubt
she's done anything
that will get her in serious trouble and
this is of course as well this is just
salmon's opening salvo she's got to give
her defense next week
um but i don't think um despite what
political commentators like to think
about this kind of thing how terribly
important it must be
and the conservatives are desperate to
find a way to get rid of sturgeon
because it would
make boris johnson's job as minister of
the union which he's handling very badly
a lot easier
i don't think most voters are going to
care i'm going to move for someone if
that's all right tim i see you want to
come back on that
um yeah go on very quickly
very quickly i largely agree with what
susie says but i think the scottish
voters are interested in the failure of
the scottish government on drugs and
education policy etc
and if they start to connect the idea
that nicolas sturgeon's been playing
political
games when she should have been focusing
on her day job then it does become an
issue
okay so let's move on only because i
want to get through a few more stories
if i can the front page of the eye
susie over 40s to get vaccine in april
and this is the decision
by the body that advises the government
on the prioritizing
of jabs they're putting age before
profession in the next
stage yeah uh they decided that age is
the dominant factor in covert deaths and
it's
easier and quicker to roll things out
according to age
than it is to roll it out according to
risk and i think everyone can appreciate
that someone who is of
extreme old age is obviously at more
risk than anything else if you're in
your 90s or 80s or 70s it's fair enough
that you get
um vaccinated but we're in a situation
at the moment where there are 60
somethings
who haven't been vaccinated and
30-somethings who are getting invited
for a jab
who aren't front-line workers and once
you get into
the working generation you get into
different kinds of risk i am at far less
risk
working here in this desk as a
40-something
than you know a 30-something who is
teaching children
and she may have not very much risk as
far as the
um the facts as far as the death from
kobe is concerned but if you're going to
be working with
people who are walking disease vectors
whether you're a police officer or a
prison officer or a shop worker or a
teacher
you're at far more risk than a
40-something white-collar
professional and i just i don't see that
it's really fair it may be slower to
roll it out
by vote by um profession by job but i
think it would be fairer
well yes that was the argument wasn't it
today's news conference the deputy chief
medical officer jonathan van tan said it
was more important to be in a queue
moving quickly
than worrying about your position in the
queue what's your take on it tim
i think we have to on this issue i have
a lot of
uh sympathy for teachers and you know
the police have been protesting today
talking about how you know they are
often in the front line they get spat up
by people
and they're very anxious about their
security in a covid
world but you know if we start to sort
of
uh give a priority to frontline groups
that should also include supermarket
workers it should include
and a whole range of other people who
are in the front line
and that does start to deny um access
to the vaccine quickly for for more
vulnerable age groups
and so i it's a very difficult situation
we of course all want
everyone to have the vaccine as quickly
as possible but
the government has given this decision
to medical
experts and the medical experts who are
studying how to best deliver a vaccine
think this is the best way forward and
so
and i think that although it's a
difficult decision i'm going to respect
the process that the government has uh
has carried out
okay until last week the experts said
that those with mild and moderate
learning disabilities didn't need the
vaccine and now they do
so they change their minds okay
don't change their mind perhaps not
politicians we really are taking a break
now
do stay with us though lots to talk
about in just a moment including we're
going to be talking about the fresh
prince of hot air
that's how the daily star calls prince
harry they're saying more publicity for
publicity shy
bloke too harsh we'll be talking about
in a moment
just that first lock down and having the
kind of um
the first few days of it or the first
few weeks of it and being kind of
rudderless and trying to work out where
you're i mean how to deal with it
basically
and i suppose as a kind of creative
person or a writer you sort of have that
added
thing of trying to work out what you
should be doing what you should be
writing
and i had other projects that i was
trying to do and difficult to
concentrate on
then in the evenings i'd write stuff
about lockdown and that was kind of
yeah obviously much more therapeutic and
enjoyable so i kind of cleared the decks
and tried to get rid of everything else
and then just um went to be fair quite
deep state and just
uh wrote about the lockdown from inside
the lockdown
the first kind of um part of writing the
book was just
sort of documenting stuff that had
happened during the
during the lockdown and during the
pandemic but then i started writing
conversations and kind of
jotting down the conversations i was
having which is the other strand of the
book
and so yeah there's something about when
i reread the book now with a bit of
space behind it
there's something about the poems just
kind of um you know setting out what
happened in the lockdown and what was
going on in march april may
june of last year and then meanwhile
yes a deterioration of my own
well-being i mean my sort of personal
lockdown was i mean everyone has their
kind of story or where they fit in
mine was living on my own in a flat in
lockdown so it was kind of
i mean i was sort of you know ramping it
up a bit but yeah a guy kind of
trying to stay sane during lockdown was
is kind of the way that the story goes
and yeah certainly in the story i
completely fall apart i mean in real
life
ironically i didn't fall apart because i
was writing the story i think that was
what was happening
but i mean with a bit more distance i'll
probably work out slightly more
what was going on the parks got full
the government waved through a new
policy stacking
now groups were allowed to assemble on
top of one another up to five groups of
ten could stack like this
park wardens enforced a strict two meter
gap in between stacks
joggers weave between the stacks and
sometimes clambered over them
they'd rest on top of the revelers and
drink cider before scrambling back down
and jogging on once more
snorting panting slaloming between these
government-sanctioned piles of
irrepressible humanity
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight the daily mirror
economist suzie boniface and the
conservative commentator tim montgomery
welcome back to both of you
and susie your paper the daily mirror is
has put prince harry on its front page
after he's done an interview with the
chat show host james corden in l.a
hasn't he they're saying queen's as
happy as harry so
what's the story behind that headline
yeah they've uh seemed to have spoken to
someone who says that uh
harry and the queen have been having
private phone calls obviously as you
would do to grandmother and grandson
and that she's happy that he's happy if
you like which is what any grandmother
would say
and it's not particularly surprising
because they're people and it's a family
at the end of the day
but it kind of shows i think that it's
the fact that we ask this particular
family of people
to be more than just people we ask them
to be symbols and when you are a symbol
it it's impossible to do all the normal
things that normal people do you can't
have an opinion even if you do good work
if you make a speech it has to be
checked
and those are the things that harry and
megan and
other members of the royal family as
well to be fair struggled with
so much that being a symbol was
something that they just found too
difficult and he's
fortunate in being the second son and
that he was able to step away prince
william
wanted to probably quite a few times in
his life
and wasn't able to because of his
position um and
you know it's nice to know that there is
still some normal human family behavior
going on there because we tend to just
treat them as a soap opera
but this is you know we ask a group of
people to act as symbols
and it's always going to cause misery
and unhappiness well yes and
and clearly uh prince harry in this
interview with james corden
still very upset about the press doesn't
like him at all he wouldn't like the
daily stars front page would he
tim they're calling him the fresh fresh
prince of hot air and implying
that he's being hypocritical because
he's carrying out this interview where
he talks about quite personal things
um he they say more publicity for
publicity
shy bloke is that a fair criticism or
should he be allowed to just control
what's in the public domain and what
isn't
i do i'm afraid think there's a bit of
them wanting their cake and
eating it you know i i wish them nothing
but happiness i hope
they find joy in there in their private
lives but
you know this idea that they are
constantly complaining about the way
the media uh treat them and then they
seem to be courting
media opportunities on a grand scale and
you know going down
a future whereby with contracts with
netflix and i think audible
trying to you know really take advantage
of their celebrity royal
status to earn money and to be in that
uh public world which of course is where
megan came from they do seem to be
contradicting their own um complaint
really okay
something i'm sure we'll return to and
discuss at length another time but we're
out of time for now
susie and tim thank you i'll see you
again at 11 30.